voilà pour cette page cinéma qui
s'annonce maintenant nous repartons sur
la croisette à cannes
le héros de la chanson de roland dagher
est de nassera tout cas hoskins qui se
présente aujourd'hui en compétition
comme un lauréat très possible du prix
d'interprétation dans le rôle de wozzeck
mise en scène par werner herzog
il est bouleversant m'être dit georges
bellour klaus kinski n'est pas un acteur
tout à fait comme les autres il ne se
contente pas de jouer il devient
littéralement le personnage qu'il
interprète
si bien qu'il lui est difficile vous le
verrez de retrouver ensuite sa propre
identité
finalement
ainslie vortex et la souffrance la folie
d'un homme qui vit avec la nature sa
propre nature et se heurtent à des murs
que ses coups de tête ne prendront
jamais je n'ai peut-être pas le plus
grand film de werner herzog mais c'est
sûrement la plus belle interprétation le
klaus kinski exact c'est prendre pas
pour le mettre en scène pour lui le mot
met en scène m m enfin une chose
manipuler diriger un acteur il refuse
il dit même si gaza côté a eu d'issue
pas le mettre en scène alors et en
conséquence il
il approche avec toute sa fonctionnalité
et s'approche à moins de me faire
comprendre qu'ils mettent à comprendre
qu'est-ce qu'on veut nous deux ensemble
ça
rien vient de là tous vient d'ici il vit
pousse bien décidé madame des masses et
france et tout ça mon instant
et depuis toujours jean qui est
réincarné qu'on ne découvre pas contre
les coréens conscient ou inconscient
toujours parce que je crois la la voie
monsieur parce que je crois la création
et rien qu'à non permanents en
conséquence je suis ça je rends qui a
été incarné c'est à dire que j'étais
prête
je suis je suis comme le mans jd aguirre
j'essaie d'aider des boîtes sec
c'était notre quartier j'étais pousse
pousse pousse chris et moi je me
souviens une chose qui vraiment le plus
commandes il est prononcé vieux
ex-égérie si vous voulez après votre 7
10 mois jusqu'à deux mois maintenant ça
va du mois vous pouvez plus décoller
plus libéré des white sox et des
traumatisés vraiment traumatisé j'ai eu
les fièvres la nuit même attendant le
tournage pour les tentes le temps je
pourrai me libérer seulement parce que
je commençais à notre fille
sophie loubière